[Music]
let's go out to amarillo texas 806 and
talk to beth what's going on beth
hi dr john i'm super excited to talk to
you today i am equally excited to talk
to you how are you
i'm doing good feeling really optimistic
about our call hopefully i'll learn
something new well i'm optimistic that i
won't screw this up for you and
whoever it is you're calling about so
what's up okay so i'm wondering how i
can help my husband see that his bone
use is impacting or like hindering our
relationship and his relationship with
our kid
you should text him
that was a fantastic joke that might
help
it probably would help so tell me what's
going on
okay so i'll give you kind of like a
rundown of what our days look like um
recently and this isn't always but just
here more recently he goes to work and
when he comes home it's just facing the
phone until pretty much until we go to
bed
what's he doing on that phone
so
he doesn't have a great separation
between
work
and home which is fine because it he
can't always have that with what he does
so i understand that but
what's he do
he's in real estate he does a lot of
different
real estate stuff just he flips houses
sells houses
has airbnbs so there's a lot of stuff
that kind of he's got he's just got it
going on
yeah it's it's good job all right so
he's got it going on he gets home he
gets off of work but he's never off of
work he just moves his body to a new
physical location
pretty much and it happens to plop right
in the middle of you and how old are
your kids
our kids are three and four months old
oh jeez
so so i'm
yeah i am i am
i've lived this life
i was your husband
and i lost
years with my family
to a stupid cell phone
i lost them and
i can get i can get emotional if i let
myself because they're gone i can never
ever have them back
and there will come a moment when the
light bell
the light bulb will go off
that one more
solving a dishwasher issue at one of the
bed and breakfast one of the
whatever it is yeah
wasn't worth
losing my three-year-old to my
five-year-old and my seven-year-old to
my nine-year-old
that's what i cashed it in for dealing
with a with a
a lawnmower issue dealing with a
drywall issue all right been there right
so been there
so tell me about how you've tried to
talk to him about it
well
the issue that we're kind of having
recently is
he's on his phone and it i can't tell
the difference between him just
scrolling through facebook and him you
know typing out an email like from my
perspective i can't tell the difference
and just so you're
not no you're not crazy there is no
difference okay none
especially to those in relationship or
trying to be in relationship around a
person who is addicted to their cell
phone
there is no difference i don't care why
you're on it you just are you're just
not with me
yeah
you're not present with us you are here
and
not here can i tell you something
bananas there's actually some research
on this
okay when somebody is
at work when they're gone there's a
physical separation in a
your body knows they're gone
when they come back
in your presence but they're not present
there's parts of your brain that
recognizes they are there and there's
parts of your brain that recognizes they
are not there
and it makes you crazy
i'm feeling it it makes you nuts and it
makes your kids bonkers because they see
dad there but dad's not there and our
brains aren't designed for that
our brains are not here
unplugged here plugged
plugged in
so
when you talk to him he says no i've got
to deal with this like tell me tell me
what his responses are
so
unfortunately like when he's on his
phone and i try to spark a conversation
he just absolutely doesn't hear me and
that's one of the main issues that i'm
having is
i can ask a question three times before
he ever looks up to acknowledge me
or same with my children he'll they'll
ask my three-year-old to ask him the
same question three times before he ever
looks up and like says anything um
i think his he just is self-proclaimed
one track minded which i just kind of
like it's bullcrap
yeah like you hear me
yeah you know so let me ask you this
what is he hiding from in your marriage
i don't think it's necessarily anything
within our own marriage if i'm being
honest i think he's just tired
i think it is hiding from something
um and i'm not saying he's having an
affair that's what i'm saying
i'm saying
whatever he comes home to
is he is decided
or
actually is there's a
toxic combination of both those
he can't handle it
and so this phone is a drink and another
drink and another drink this phone is a
joint
this phone is a
six-pack of tall boys this phone is a
bag of gummy candies
it is a way to numb out and disappear
i'm fulfilling my role my body is here
nobody can say i'm i'm not present or i
don't care about my kids
but i cannot i'm hiding in my own house
yeah
um
i don't know i think
truthfully before we had our second son
we did a lot of
you know
our happy moments were sitting down and
really getting to talk to each other and
kind of tell each other what's going on
in our days and
you know we would do that when we would
take our our oldest to the park and then
when we had uh our second son things
kind of got flipped upside down he was
sick for a few months and we just kind
of went into survival mode
and i think we've pulled back from a
little bit of that
conversational intimacy but then
that also
kind of trickles down into
physical intimacy as well so maybe it
has to do with that
so
physical intimacy and relational
intimacy are one and the same they're
intimately linked
and they work they're recursive
they work together and sometimes couples
get on either side of those things like
i feel more relational when we're having
sex and i feel more relational when
we're
chit chatting which leads to more sex
which leads to more relation right
people approach that thing differently
and it's at different times in different
seasons and all that stuff
i would guess your husband's never got
out of survival mode
and when you got fight fight or freeze
after a couple of months of fighting or
of sprinting around everywhere
frantically
at some point your body just says i
can't keep doing this so i'm unplugging
and
there probably has never been a
conversation a time a family retreat
y'all two go spend a half day together
where one of you has the courage to say
we just went through hell
and we made it
and here we are
and now what
yeah and if you don't have that
conversation
your body will be trying to solve for
that disconnection
for years
until somebody at work texts you and
your heart starts beating faster again
for the first time and all of a sudden
you find yourself in a situation you
never intended to be in
or
he just
completely unplugs from everything
till you and the kids create all lives
and then he just doesn't have to i mean
he just goes off to his thing
right which i know like that would be
not at all what he wants like he
literally has a heart of gold absolutely
you know and
i know his picture for what he would
want his family life to be like and it's
just not what it is right now there you
go there you go and so i want to look at
yes the phone is the issue right now
but the phone is the issue there's a
deeper issue underneath the phone which
is
you don't feel connected in your
marriage anymore you bath
you you and your husband haven't
reset control alt deleted after your
little boy was born he was sick and you
all went through
um chaos and chaos and chaos
you often said
y'all are still sprinting
yeah
and he has found himself in a world he
doesn't love in a situation not not he
doesn't love you do you want to say but
he's found himself in a world that he
doesn't want
and he's trapped he's an addict
and
you may have heard me say this but
all addiction is when your anxiety
alarms are going off your depression
alarm's going awesome you crawl up in
the kitchen and your smoke detector's
going off and you just take a pillow and
you duct tape it around the pillow i
mean around the alarm just so it'll be
quiet
and that's all that phone is
and he found himself with a
four-year-old and a young kid or
two-year-old young kid and he doesn't
know how to engage with him and he found
himself with a wife that he remembers
deep talks with and he remembers
crazy bonker sex with and and now it's
just y'all are running a business
together and he just goes down the phone
yeah
and those things turn into spirals and
all of a sudden you find yourselves two
inches apart on the couch and two
thousand miles away from each other
right
right
so here's what i'll tell you the worst
time to have a conversation about the
cell phone is when he's holding the cell
phone
which is hard because he's always
holding himself up
here's what um
here's what i want you to do this is
going to take some bravery on your part
it's going to be a risk
i want you to tell him
i need to put the phone down and hold
both of my hands and look at me in my
eyes
and he'll go oh
[Music]
have him do that
and if you won't do it you're gonna have
to write this down on a piece of paper
and a letter
nah he'll do it okay
say
i have booked us a night at a hotel
and i have or i have booked us a at some
restaurant here in marilla
um i've got child care for us
we have two little ones
we're disconnected and i want to talk
about what comes next in our marriage
will you please join me and here's the
rule about this this time together
no phones none zero
okay okay
and if he says well just can't i want
you to tell him
i want to talk about the future of our
marriage
and i want to have no phones when we
have this conversation
and i need you to say it like that so he
feels you and hears you
okay and
let's be real
there's a part of you that is scared
that you are losing him am i right
yeah there's a part of you that is
scared because he's going away like
you're holding sand and he's just
falling through your fingers
and if he can't hear you he needs to
hear honey i'm scared about what
tomorrow's going to look like for us
because right now
you're more interested in your phone
than you are your wife and kids
and i'm asking you to come spend some
time with me so we can talk about what
comes next without a phone
and in the meantime
i know it's a pain in the butt but i
want you to get some child care you all
go spend a half day together but i want
you to write down your concerns your
thoughts your dreams what are you
missing it can't just get somewhere and
be like dude you got to deal with that
phone cause he'll deal with the phone
for a month and he'll turn into somebody
who has one too many drinks or it's
always out with this what it'll turn
into another thing not actually
addressing this there you go
okay
i would love for you to go back and say
we went into survival mode when our
youngest one was sick
and
i miss you
what does it look like
for us to
start sleeping together again what does
it look like for us to start having
chit chats again when you get home
what's it look like for you to come home
and from five to nine pm there are no
cell phones and you have somebody else
that can take that call i'd rather spend
the money than lose my husband what's it
look like for you to
go play with our kids with no phone
but i need this phone to be that will
come up but that's not the that's not
the root the root is
he's exhausted he's checked out
and you saying i want you back and he
may say i thought you checked out and so
i got scared and so i checked out
that's probably what will happen
and you'll have to hear some hard stuff
too probably is that fair
yeah which i'm
that's another reason that i'm a little
bit
hesitant to bring stuff up with him is
because
he never complains about anything that
i'm falling behind on like i feel so
guilty trying to point out something
that
he's doing that's
impact or like that's not my favorite
because i don't i never want to be the
type of wife
that is nagging and i don't want him to
feel like i am
and he never complains about
anything that i do and i know i'm not
perfect
and so i don't want it to be this
one-sided well i'm just doing what she
says to keep her happy
and i it would go a long way for him to
hear from you
like what do you want hon
what do you want this
let's paint a picture of this thing
we've got two little ones now they're
both safe they're both healthy they're
both doing okay we get to decide what
this marriage looks like
and four hours on a phone until you
collapse from the tv that just seems
like a like a
what a waste of the one reckless
precious life we got
yeah
and i'll tell you two things number one
you're right nagging does never solves
anything
but choose guilt over resentment every
time you've heard me say that i'll say
it a million more times
choose guilt
choose hey i need you i'm missing you
over saying nothing because you're going
to say nothing long enough
and then you're all of a sudden you're
going to say it's going to turn to i'll
screw you man
yeah
and then it's hard to come back from
that
and by the way nobody's perfect in a
relationship nobody's perfect
and it's not a competition well he never
complained so i can never complain no
i think complaining is a waste of time
telling somebody i miss you and i love
you and that phone is between us that's
not complaining
going get off your phone get off your
phone get off your phone that's
complaining
you know what i mean
and once you have this hard conversation
once you'll go out and have breakfast
together and you come back and he pops
that phone up
he's making a choice
and that choice is that little five-inch
screen over his wife and his children
and that's why this whole thing's a risk
it's scary because he could choose that
phone he could choose well i'm gonna buy
houses i'm flipping stuff whatever he
could keep choosing and choosing and
choosing
and that's why this whole thing is
you're way out on a limb here but i
don't think that's the kind of guy he is
from what you've told me
i want him to hear i miss you
and i'm not done fighting for you
i'm going all in on you
let's get this thing back and not only
now let's don't get this thing back
let's build something new scratch that i
shouldn't have said that i hate when
people say that we're not getting
anything back we're going to build
something new we're going to build
something incredible
let's do this together
you're awesome beth he's lucky to have
you let's
have these conversations and let me know
how that breakfast goes i can't wait to
hear about it i can't wait to hear about
it